Elle a tellement ri qu'elle a fait un malaise là.
Nan mais là on a un problème.
Vous savez que c'est une obligation légale d'aller à la police quand on a un cadavre sur les bras.
On n'aurait jamais dû faire ça.
On a voté hein.
Nan, parce qu'il n'y a pas une seule personne ici qui a un plan.
Bah si, on a qu'à l'enterrer dans la forêt communale, personne la trouvera là-bas.
Mais on peut pas, dès qu'on y creuse, on t'emmerde, ils vont trouver.
En plus ça appartient à la ville.
Sinon, on la jette dans la Vilaine et puis salut...
Nan, parce qu'écologiquement, c'est pas possible, et le bien commun, merci.
Et puis ça va nous faire une affaire Grégory numéro 2, c'est moyen moyen quand même.
C'est sûr que si on pouvait aller en Antarctique, ça réglerait le problème.
C'est loin, c'est froid et ça appartient à personne.
Alors...
À qui appartient l’Antarctique ?
Parce-que même si vous n’êtes pas juriste, le droit international, pour la base, on sait un peu comment ça se passe.
Au sens du droit, un État, c’est 3 éléments.
Un territoire, même si, dans de nombreux pays, les frontières sont parfois contestées et l’objet de conflit.
Une population sur ce territoire, qui va être soumis aux règles de droit de cet État.
Et un pouvoir institutionnalisé, avec un gouvernement qui va avoir certaines prérogatives.
Ca inclut les cas également où le pouvoir n’est pas légitime,
où le gouvernement n’est pas démocratique, où il y a des luttes internes etc.
Mais pour l’Antarctique, vous conviendrez que c’est un peu plus compliqué car l’Antarctique n’est pas un Etat mais un continent tout entier.
Mais pour le grand public, l’Antarctique, à part savoir le situer et savoir qu’il y fait globalement très froid, on en sait pas grand chose.
L'Antarctique est donc le continent le plus méridional de la Terre,
avec une superficie de 14 millions de kilomètres carrés,
oui moi non plus je me rends pas compte de ce que ça fait,
donc dites vous que l’Antarctique est plus grand que l’Europe et que l’Océanie.
14 millions de km² oui, mais ça, c'est en été !
Car en hiver, ça double, l’eau de mer va geler et on dépasse les 30 millions de km² en moyenne !
L’Antarctique a des températures pouvant aller jusqu’à - 80 °C et c’est le dernier continent à avoir été exploré.
C'est marrant parce que du point de vue géologique, c'est hyper intéressant l'Antarctique.
En fait sur la partie Est,
on trouve des roches qui ont 3 milliards d'années,
quand tu sais que la Terre entière a 4,5 milliards d'années, c'est vraiment des roches de sa prime jeunesse.
- Ah oui !
- Oui c'est ultra-rare en fait.
C'est un peu comme si tu marchais et tu tombais sur ses dents de lait.
À condition que tu marches en Antarctique.
Mais il y a sans doute plein de trésors qu'on n'a pas encore découvert en Antarctique,
parce que 98% de sa surface est recouverte de glace.
Une couche qui fait 2 km d'épaisseur, c'est énorme.
Il y a plus de 70 millions d'années en fait,
ça faisait partie du supercontinent Gondwana et c'était sous un climat tropical.
Le Gondwana, c'était un peu le pré-Pangée, tu vois ?
Et là, il pouvait y avoir des jungles tropicales,
tu imagines, avec des fougères, les ancêtres des kangourous.
C'était la folie.
Et puis, il s'est détâché peu à peu de l'Australie,
et au dernier moment de l'Amérique du Sud.
Puis à ce moment-là, une fois qu'il était tout seul, il y a un courant qui s'est mis en place tout autour,
qui s'appelle le courant circumpolaire antarctique, c'est le plus puissant qu'on connaisse sur Terre.
Et ça, c'est vraiment un moteur du climat à l'échelle globale.
Parce que d'une part, ça empêche les eaux chaudes de redescendre
et de toucher les côtes antarctiques, donc ça garde le climat
le climat très froid en Antarctique même.
En plus, ça permet de remonter les eaux froides
qui sont en profondeur, sous l'océan,
et c'est en fait c'est ça qui fait le moteur de la circulation thermohaline.
C'était le tapis roulant des océans.
Tu traces une molécule d'eau à un endroit donné
tu peux la laisser nager, elle fera le tour de tous les océans
et elle reviendra au même endroit, dans 1000 ans ou 1500 ans à peu près.
Et aujourd'hui, on le sait pas forcément, mais c'est un climat extrêmement froid, ça on sait, et il est sec aussi.
Parce qu'il ne pleut quasiment pas là-bas, c'est en fait le plus grand désert du monde l'Antarctique.
Et du coup, tu as une faune et une flore très particulière qui s'est développée là-bas.
Tu n'auras pas d'arbre, mais tu auras des herbes, des algues, du lychen, des trucs comme ça.
Puis en animaux, tu auras des manchots, des phoques et puis le cadavre d'explorateurs un peu trop hardis.
Donc voilà, tout ça pour dire qu'il n'y a pas de population indigène en Antarctique, on n'en a pas trouvé en tout cas.
Ok... c'est pas trop le moment Valentine par contre.
Depuis quand sait-on que l’Antarctique existe ?
Parce-que même si c’est de l’Histoire, on peut aisément deviner que c’est à partir de là que remontent les questionnements
concernant à qui cela appartenait,
et éventuellement le début des premières sources de droit sur le sujet.
Alors, on a quelques traces des premières spéculations sur l’existence de l’Antarctique
qui remontent à l’Antiquité, avec la dénomination “Terra Australis”,
autrement dit Terre Australe.
Plus tard, on voit cette dénomination reportée sur diverses cartes comme sur celle d'Abraham Ortelius en 1570
ou cette carte de 1771.
On voit que les contours restent très vagues et globalement, de cette terre australe,
on ne sait pas grand chose.
Ce ne sera qu’en 1819 qu’on peut formellement attester qu’on connaissait l’Antarctique.
C’est le navigateur britannique William Smith qui fera cette observation.
L’Antarctique suscite alors bien plus d’intérêts, subissant alors une intense chasse aux phoques,
ce qui mènera à une quasi-extinction de certaines espèces.
Eh, vous savez qu'il existe quatre espèces de manchot.
Nan.
On va faire pas mal d’histoire et de géopolitique,
et même un peu de géographie, car tous ces éléments sont indispensables pour comprendre les enjeux de l’Antarctique.
Puis le droit ça me saoule, je cherche un plan de reconversion aussi.
Lire un texte juridique, que ce soit une loi ou un traité international n’a pas beaucoup de substance si on ne s’intéresse pas au contexte.
Contexte ?
Sans ça, on ne s’intéresserait qu’à la loi “brute” si j’ose dire, et on perdrait des informations très précieuses.
D’ailleurs, la loi ne peut pas toujours tout préciser et anticiper tous les cas de figure.
C’est donc le juge notamment qui va finir par trancher, avec son pouvoir d’interprétation de la loi.
Et une loi, ça ne s’interprète pas avec notre petit avis sur la question.
On va s’intéresser à quel était l’objectif poursuivi par ceux qui l’ont écrite,
et donc, on va devoir comprendre le contexte de son écriture.
Ce sont ces éléments qui vont nous permettre de répondre aux interrogations dont la réponse n’est pas écrite noire sur blanc.
- Et c’est un exercice passionnant !
- NAN !
En 1959, 12 pays signent le premier traité international au sujet de l’Antarctique.
On y reviendra un tout petit peu plus tard, car je suis obligée de faire un état des lieux avant de vous parler du traité plus en profondeur.
Parce-qu’avant 1959, est-ce-que l’Antarctique était une zone non revendiquée et neutre,
est-ce qu’on voulait juste le marquer dans le marbre du traité pour éviter toutes dérives ?
Evidemment que non !
Certains Etats avaient bien des revendications sur le sujet et plus exactement, sept.
Les 5 premiers sont le Royaume-Uni, la France, l’Australie, la Nouvelle-Zélande et la Norvège
qui argumentent leur légitimité de possession
avec les découvertes réalisées au 19e siècle.
Ils se sont donc accordés des “droits historiques” sur des bandes de terre de l’Antarctique,
répartis en triangles allant de la côte jusqu’au pôle.
En gros, premier arrivé, premier servi.
En 1940, deux pays vont se rajouter aux 5 premiers,
l’Argentine et le Chili,
clamant leurs droits notamment au prétexte d’une “continuité géographique”.
On est en bas, donc c'est à nous.
Evidemment, ça a créé un conflit puisque les zones revendiquées par l’Argentine et le Chili
appartenaient déjà au Royaume-Uni.
Vous voyez, les “FIRST” sous les vidéos Youtube ont toujours existé finalement.
Entre 1957 et 1958, se tient “l’année géophysique internationale”
qui a pour but de mener des recherches en Antarctique.
Beaucoup de bases scientifiques se sont installées là-bas pour réaliser des recherches
et il apparaissait absolument nécessaire de pouvoir les encadrer
pour éviter qu’on y fasse tout et n’importe quoi.
Surtout, lorsque l’année géophysique internationale prend fin,
l’URSS veut potentiellement maintenir ses bases sur le territoire,
et ça effraie un peu les Etats-Unis qui veulent évidemment ne pas rester sur la touche.
Attendez... 1959 ?
Ouais, la Guerre Froide !
Ça change tout !
Donc forcément, l’Antarctique va devenir lui-même un enjeu.
Parce-qu’il est effectivement faux de penser que l’Antarctique n’intéressait personne à l’époque,
et ce, pour 2 raisons.
Déjà, c’est un lieu stratégique, à 1000 kilomètres du cap Horn.
donc à l'extrémité de l’Amérique du Sud.
Si le canal de Panama était fermé, et que l’Antarctique devenait une zone de conflits,
on ne pouvait plus communiquer entre l’océan Pacifique et l’océan Atlantique.
Mais aussi, car l’Antarctique contient énormément de ressources minières, notamment du charbon et du pétrole,
ce genre de trucs qui attirent pas du tout les convoitises et les conflits, hein.
On voit donc qu’on a déjà quelques conflits, entre l’Argentine et le Chili vis-à-vis du Royaume-Uni,
et évidemment, entre l’URSS et les Etats-Unis.
Il est donc important de négocier dès maintenant pour couper court à une éventuelle escalade des tensions,
c’est la guerre froide on rappelle donc c'est chaud !
Les Etats-Unis invitent à la table des négociations les pays qui ont participé aux recherches scientifiques sur le continent,
donc la Grande Bretagne, la France, l’Australie, la Nouvelle-Zélande et la Norvège
qui ont déjà leur petite part de camembert ;
l’Argentine et le Chili qui ont des revendications ;
L'URSS... et l'Afrique du Sud, la Belgique et le Japon ?
Qu'est-ce qu'ils font là eux en fait ?
Ces 12 pays vont se réunir à Washington
et au terme des négociations,
parviendront à signer en 1959
le très sobrement intitulé “traité sur l’Antarctique”.
et qui va donc réglementer les relations entre les Etats signataires.
Par ailleurs, ce traité n’est pas très long, seulement 7 pages regroupant 13 articles.
Comme je vous le disais, cette signature se fait un an après l’année géophysique internationale,
où beaucoup de scientifiques se sont penchés sur le sujet.
Il faut donc préserver la zone et l’inscrire dans les textes,
notamment pour continuer à mener des recherches scientifiques dans de bonnes conditions.
L’objectif poursuivi par le traité est donc inscrit noir sur blanc dès son introduction,
sous la formule qu’il est “de l’intérêt de l’humanité tout entière que l’Antarctique soit à jamais réservée
aux seules activités pacifiques et ne devienne ni le théâtre ni l’enjeu de différends internationaux”.
L’article 1er donne tout de suite le ton :
Article 1, petit 1 :
Seules les activités pacifiques sont autorisées dans l’Antarctique.
Sont interdites, entre autres, toutes mesures de caractère militaire telles que l’établissement de bases,
la construction de fortifications, les manœuvres, ainsi que les essais d’armes de toutes sortes.
Petit 2 : le présent Traité ne s’oppose pas à l’emploi de personnel ou de matériel militaires
pour la recherche scientifique ou pour toute autre fin pacifique”
Donc, on autorise seulement les activités pacifiques en Antarctique,
c’est donc une façon de couper l’herbe sous le pied à d’éventuelles mises en place de bases militaires ou pire,
la réalisation d’essais nucléaires.
Enterrer ses morts, c'est une activité pacifique en tout cas, elle est vieille comme le monde.
Ça déclenche pas une guerre nucléaire.
Ça c'est toi qui le dit.
Ouais parce qu'ils ont l’air un peu vénère quand même les mecs pour 4 manchots et un peu de poudreuse.
Mais vous vous doutez bien que les discussions restent quelque peu intéressées,
et faut pas déconner, on va pas renoncer à certains de nos acquis.
Aucun des 5 Etats qui se sont découpées l’Antarctique ne va renoncer à sa souveraineté sur les terres qu’ils convoitent,
on l’a marqué noir sur blanc à l’article 4 du traité.
Donc sur ce point précis, on glisse de façon à peine dissimulée le sujet sous le tapis,
c’est un peu leur “on verra plus tard” mais en mieux dit quoi.
Toutefois, le gros point de réussite de ce traité,
c’est que l’objectif de préservation de la zone à des fins de recherches scientifiques est atteint.
Le traité met même en place une coopération entre les Etats,
pour qu’ils échangent les renseignements qu’ils ont recueilli,
dans le but, je cite, “d’assurer au maximum l’économie des moyens
et le rendement des opérations”.
L’objectif est aussi de préserver la faune et la flore,
et on prévoit même dans le traité la désignation d’observateurs
pour vérifier que toutes ces dispositions sont bien respectées.
Au moins, on prend des mesures mais pour vérifier qu’elles soient bien respectées,
on anticipe déjà un contrôle à effectuer.
Ça montre bien que ce traité est loin d’être une simple déclaration d’intention,
il y a de vraies conséquences prévues.
Et concernant les conséquences, on prévoit aussi un autre point, absolument capital.
Qu’est-ce-qu’il se passe si jamais un conflit apparaît ?
Quand on rédige un traité international, il est important d’anticiper cette question.
Qui tranchera en cas de litige ?
Ce point est évidemment une énorme lutte de pouvoirs,
puisque chaque partie au traité va essayer de faire en sorte que l’arbitre lui soit favorable.
Le traité se cantonne à expliquer qu’en premier lieu,
les parties doivent tenter de gérer leur différend par des moyens pacifiques.
Bon, jusque là, rien de très surprenant.
Si ça échoue et qu’on n’arrive pas à trouver une solution,
ce sera la Cour Internationale de Justice qui tranchera.
Sauf que là on retombe sur un problème, qui n’est pas du tout propre à l’Antarctique.
La Cour Internationale de Justice n’a que des moyens très limités,
puisqu’il est difficile d’influencer un État tout entier,
ce qui fait qu’il y a déjà eu énormément de blocages dans le passé.
Je n’ai pas vraiment le temps de développer ce point précis et je vous ai mis des sources en description
si jamais vous voulez approfondir le sujet.
Retenez simplement qu’il est difficile d’exercer une contrainte au niveau international sur un État,
parce que l’Etat reste souverain dans une certaine mesure.
Donc pour l’Antarctique, ça pourrait être la même issue.
En résumé, y a plus qu’à croiser les doigts pour qu’il n’y ait pas de souci.
Bref, on avance sur le sujet puisqu’on prend des mesures au niveau international, basé sur la coopération entre les États
et l’idée que l’Antarctique doit rester une zone neutre et pacifique.
Mais on n’a pas vraiment réglé TOUS les problèmes.
on a évité que les revendications territoriales se multiplient et s’enlisent vers quelque chose de conflictuel,
mais on reste en stand-by, on a gelé un statu-quo.
Ah oui. Je l’ai. c’est un jeu de mot en fait. Gelé, froid, Antarctique.
Ferme ta gueule !
L’avantage c’est que l’Antarctique aura permis d’apaiser certaines tensions entre les Etats-Unis et l’URSS.
À cette même période, les deux pays entreront en pourparlers concernant la limitation des essais nucléaires,
initiative couronnée de succès en 1963 !
Peut-être que cette situation d’apaisement concernant l’Antarctique a oeuvré en ce sens.
Comme il était convenu dans le traité, les parties signataires se sont par la suite réunies régulièrement.
Après la signature du traité sur l’Antarctique de 1959, on signera en 1980
la “Convention sur la conservation de la faune et la flore marines de l’Antarctique”,
qui entrera en vigueur en 1982.
Il est ensuite apparu qu’il fallait préciser certaines positions,
d’où la signature du protocole de Madrid en 1991.
Le protocole de Madrid se fait dans le même esprit que le traité de 1959,
sauf qu’il est beaucoup plus accès sur la préservation de cet espace pour des raisons environnementales.
Les parties signataires vont même convenir que l’Antarctique soit désigné comme “réserve naturelle, consacrée à la paix et à la science”
ce qui est une très jolie formule.
Le protocole va aussi créer un comité pour la protection de l’environnement,
pour tenter de limiter l’impact de l’être humain sur cette faune et cette flore si fragile et précieuse.
On cherche à rappeler au niveau international cette nécessité absolue de préservation,
en renforçant les moyens de contrôle.
Le problème, c’est que faire respecter des traités internationaux, c'est un petit peu complexe.
Une loi nationale repose sur un texte, notre juge contrôle sa bonne application et si c’est pas respecté, PAF !
En droit international, ben y a moins de contraintes parce qu'on veut aussi pousser les États à s’engager,
si on leur tape trop sur les doigts, ils viendront plus.
Trump par exemple, s’est retiré de plein de traités internationaux, et c’est compliqué à gérer.
Faut tout miser sur la bonne volonté des Etats, vous conviendrez que c’est pas évident quoi.
Les États, les mêmes qu’en 1959, continuent de revendiquer leur part,
ce qui n’est pas reconnu à l’international mais n’est pas une source de conflits non plus.
Dans les années 70 et 80, le Chili et l’Argentine ont organisé des accouchements sur leurs bases respectives
pour asseoir leurs revendications territoriales.
Genre, ils ont fait dépécher des femmes enceintes de 7 ou 8 mois
pour qu'elles accouchent sur leurs bases, en Antarctique.
Ils étaient ultra déter en fait.
Pour ce qui concerne plus particulièrement la France, nous revendiquons les Terres australes et antarctiques françaises,
abrégées par l’acronyme TAAF.
Ces terres sont considérés comme un territoire d’outre-mer, selon une loi datant de 1955,
soit avant la signature du premier traité.
Il y est même fait mention dans notre fameuse Constitution !
Mais en gros, c’est pas vraiment reconnu au niveau international.
On a aussi une autre difficulté de préservation se fait sentir, et elle est bien plus récente.
c’est celle du tourisme.
On estime qu’en 1990, il y avait 3.000 touristes à l’année en Antarctique,
et ils sont un peu plus de 37000 en 2015.
Mais ce tourisme est assez particulier.
Il est intéressant de noter que l’Association Internationale des Voyagistes Antarctiques
va concentrer le flux de plus de 80% des touristes sur ce continent.
Elle établit un code de conduite.
Le but n’est pas de faire du tourisme “classique”,
mais plus pédagogique, orienté vers une coopération avec les scientifiques.
Il est toutefois important de maintenir des règles strictes
pour que le tourisme en Antarctique ne perturbe ni la faune, ni la flore locale, ni le travail de recherche effectué sur place.
Il y a encore un enjeu de taille à relever.
En 2048, il faudra réviser les accords concernant l’Antarctique.
Pour ça, il faudra que tous les pays s'entendent et ils sont 28.
Donc, ça ne va pas être gagné, on leur souhaite bon courage.
La question revient sans cesse concernant l’extraction des ressources.
Certains pays, comme la Russie, cherchent à obtenir des autorisations pour extraire le charbon et le pétrole présents.
donc vous vous en doutez, ces extractions pourraient mettre à mal l’équilibre de cet écosystème si précieux.
2048, ça parait loin, et pas tant que ça en même temps.
Pour l’instant, la position de la France serait de faire placer l’Antarctique au patrimoine mondial de l’Unesco,
ce qui pour les experts sur le sujet,
serait probablement l’issue la plus préférable.
Concernant l’absolue nécessité de continuer à préserver cet endroit unique au monde qu’est l’Antarctique,
en refusant qu’on en extrait les ressources naturelles par exemple,
je voudrais finir en citant cet article du Monde qui date de 2011
mais qui est plus que jamais d’actualité :
“Cette menace environnementale est occultée aujourd'hui par les crises des dettes souveraines.
Le long terme disparaît devant l'urgence.
Ce n'est pas le moindre des paradoxes.
Car le système financier nous rappelle que nous finissons toujours par payer nos dettes,
comme le système climatique nous fera payer, plus tard,
la dette que nous contractons aujourd'hui en chargeant l'atmosphère de carbone.
La mise en garde s'impose donc.
Le sous-sol de l'Antarctique est peut-être diablement tentant,
mais il a tous les traits d'une boîte de Pandore. “
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu.
N'hésitez pas à la liker, à la partager,
à vous abonner et à activer la cloche.
Et puis, on se retrouvera sur Discord pour en discuter tous ensemble.
Donc, n'hésitez pas à nous rejoindre, et sur ce, je vous dis, à bientôt.
Bon du coup, il faut qu'on trouve une autre solution pour ma cousine.
Et je vous préviens tout de suite, elle mérite le respect qu'on lui doit.
Il faut trouver un endroit bien pour elle.
Ah mais, on a mangé la pintade hier.
Et alors, c'est quoi le rapport ?
C'est qu'il y a de la place dans le congel, on a qu'à la mettre là en attendant.
Je suis actuellement en live sur Twitch,
pour pouvoir débriefer l'épisode avec vous sur l'Antarctique.
N'hésitez pas à venir, je vous attends avec ceci.
C'est mon petit bout d'Antarctique à moi.
Voilà.